it is official Johnny Galecki will
appear on the Connors the Roseanne
spin-off but oh there's more and this
one is a real surprise Juliette Lewis
joins the Connors the Oscar nominee
posted pics with her script and wrote
hashtag lucky me
Giulia plays blue David's girlfriend and
he of course is played by Big Bang's
Johnny Galecki who was on one Roseanne
episode last season et has learned for
now Johnny and Juliet will each appear
in one episode of the seasons 10 episode
I love that you guys were able to work
it out and come back it wouldn't have
been the same it's a purely due to how
supportive my Big Bang family is here so
I'm very grateful the connors debuting
October 16th is a reunion for Johnny and
Juliet who were siblings on National
Lampoon's Christmas vacation meanwhile
Roseanne Barr who was fired after
sending a racially charged tweet isn't
going quietly what's gonna happen to
Roseanne Connor oh they killed her
Roseanne spotted out shopping in LA
yesterday told the YouTube site walk
away she's insulted by rumors that her
character dies of an opioid overdose
it's so cynical I mean he should have
died as a hero
[Music]
[Applause]